[Music]
don't forget to enter our December
giveaway subscribe comment and leave a
like rhaegar targaryen one of the most
important characters in the game
insurance universe the son of the mad
king the older brother of Danny and
father of jumps novels azor Ahai his
wife Lena stark net sister whose alleged
kidnapping by Prince Rhaegar contributed
the outbreak of Robert's rebellion was
his niece Aneesa and they created Jon
Snow light bringer that's the theory I'm
going to introduce you with in this
video some of you must be wondering what
are all these names
Asura hi Nissa Nissa light bringer the
princess was promised who are they and
why are they so important for the end of
the show Asura hi is a legendary figure
in the fate of the Lord of Light
thousand years ago during the long night
Asura high for the sword Lightbringer
which used to defeat the darkness of to
retire this came at the price however as
in order to unleash the sword show
powers he had to plunge it into the
heart of Islam wife nice a nice a
prophecy that was mentioned multiple
times throughout the series foretells
that azor Ahai will be reborn as the
princess was promised to defeat the
darkness and save the world from the
long night the Lord of Light is real and
if he is real then all of it is real man
once again faces the war for the dawn
which has been waged since time began on
one side is the Lord of Light the heart
of fire the god of flame and shadow
against him stands the great other whose
name may not be spoken the Lord of
Darkness the soul of ice the God of
night men to terror according to
prophecy our champion will be reborn to
wake dragons from stone and reforged the
great sword Lightbringer that defeated
the darkness those thousands of years
ago a few characters measure prophecy of
being the promised hero but the fans
just as Melisandre are growing more and
more convinced that John son of Ice and
Fire
is in fact the Lord shows if John's
social is the princess promised it would
mean that Dana's probably going to die
according to prophecy these are the
indicators of the coming of azor Ahai
after a long summer when the stars bleed
and the cold breath of darkness falls
heavy on the world he has her high shall
be born again amid smoking salt he shall
beg dragons out of stone he shall draw
from the fire burning sword Lightbringer
the prophesied Savior will also be born
from the line of House Targaryen of the
line of air is a second and relah
according to Rhaegar Targaryen he's also
the Song of Ice and Fire on the TV show
the first time we met with our highest
prophecy was the scene which Dennis
Wilson magic sword that was forged by
plunging a blade through the burning
statue of the maiden a deceptive
gemstone after Melisandre come in Stan
is dead he's the prophesied prince that
ceremony was meant to be rebirth of us
were high the burning statues of the
seven provided smoke and waves some sort
of giant stone provided the soul
although studies Baratheon does magic
scription of being born from the line of
House Targaryen because his grandmother
was a Targaryen he was not born from the
line of Madera Cinderella and also while
Stannis is sword shine thanks most
honest magic it gave off no heat
meaning that the sword could not
possibly be Lightbringer after Stannis
is defeated in battle and Jon Snow is
raised from the dead and reclaim Stannis
was not a prince but someone must be
suggesting and later confirming that she
now believes John is the prince that was
promised now let's see if Jon Snow truly
is Ezra hi
after long Samuraizer hai will be reborn
amid smokin salt prophet says this could
point on Jon's resurrection he was
reborn after he was stabbed to death by
Nights Watch traders so here we have
rebirth but what about the smoke and
soul part in prophecy well in my opinion
the wall could represent the salt since
in the books it's told that wall
contains the Sultan according from the
books the doors upper lip brushed
against the top of brains head and drop
of water fell on him and ran slowly down
his nose feel strangely warm and salty
adhere now let's see if we have the
smoke since
see clearly says that azor Ahai will be
reborn amid smokin salt well the smoke
part also came true do you remember that
masanjia Val she perform resurrection
ritual to bring John back to life do you
remember the most logical ox of John's
hair and tells the curls and of the
flames after Richard saw the smoke it
said it brings those promise should have
the blood of a dragon should be born of
the line of the Mad King Aerys Targaryen
and relative Gary John matches the
description as well as his the son of
Rhaegar and therefore heir SunRail are
Jon's grandparents before I continue let
me just highlighted the showrunners know
from George our man himself was her hi
is and therefore we should pay attention
to every single detail that hints
through the prophesied savior is no
matter how small
without being said let's go back to the
final episode of season 6 beside veiling
that Lina Stark is John's matter they
also revealed that John was born under a
billion star which fulfills the part of
the prophecy which says the prince was
promised will be born under a blazing
star as we could see other stark enter
the tower of Jovita bloodied sword on
ancestral sword which was forged from a
fallen star the stone covered in blood
counts for being born under bleeding
star yeah I think it does it's also
important to highlight a few other facts
like for an example when lil Sancho
looks into her fire to see us Orihime
lsanty only sees things related to
either John or snow the second thing
that I'd highlight is John's dream that
he dreamed in books a dream in which she
fights the other suitor red sword
burning in his sand in the his vision of
past in a clash of kings Rhaegar also
says that his son is the brain that was
promised and his song is the Song of Ice
and Fire
however it's not only John who matches
the description of the prophesied Savior
the nurse does as well which another red
priestess recognized you should have
told me who doesn't want to meet the
Savior the High Priestess of the temple
is though CERN their Danny's the one who
was promised Daenerys Stormborn is the
one who was promised from the fire she
was reborn to remake the world yes
she has freed the slaves from their
chains and crucify the masters for their
sins she did indeed her dragons are fire
made flesh a gift from the Lord of Light
but you heard all of this before having
to you in the long bridge of volantis
even though Sanjay upon learning of
Danny and her dragons comes to
Dragonstone to state her new belief it's
not only John who is tied to the other
high prophecy it's both the John and
Danny
Melisandre told Danny that she has a
role to play in the prophecy as does Jon
Snow give your daughter Larry's Ozma
Hagen contas the prince who is promised
will bring the door I'm afraid I'm not a
prince your grace
forgive me but your translation is not
quite accurate that's now has no gender
in high Valyrian so the proper
translation for that prophecy would be
the prince or princess there was
promised or bring the dawn doesn't
really roll off the tongue does it no
but I like it better and you believe
this prophecy refers to me prophecies
are dangerous things I believe you have
a role to play as does another the king
in the north
Jon Snow since both John and Danny are
tied to the other high prophecy which
includes a historic legend of a hare
sacrificing his life in or say the world
from the long night many fans
interpreted an Israel in long night most
likely being her eventual sacrifice and
death basically in that theory after
huge amount of casualties and upon
realizing that their chance to survive
the long knife is small John really
realized that he has to do something
horrible in order to end the long night
in order to save all innocent people
from a certain death John will have to
kill Danny in the final episodes of the
series this year would make a lot of
sense if Jon Snow truly is the brains
that was promised since it had to create
a library to defeat the darkness and in
order to do so he'd have to kill the law
his life deign just as the original azor
Ahai thousands of years ago had to in
order to end along night
but what if John is not a prince that
was promised but is the library nur this
theory the man they prophesied in the
ancient books is actually Rhaegar
Targaryen
Oleanna was his niece Anissa whom
Rhaegar sacrifice by creating the
library nur Jon Snow the one who will
bring the dawn so basically regard the
princess promised to defeat the knight
in the same way the original azor Ahai
did at his fabled weapon light bringer
except in this case light bringer is not
sword but where a person named John Snow
in his youth Rhaegar Targaryen himself I
shall believe that he was the prophesied
Prince and so did his great great uncle
mr. Rehman before they both become
convinced that the saber was actually
Rhaegar son aegon instead this is what
maester aemon had to say about the
prophecy in a feast for crows Rhaegar I
thought the smoke was from the fire that
devoured summerhall on the day of his
birth the soul from tears shed for those
who died he shed my belief when he was
young but later he became persuaded that
it was his own son who fulfilled the
prophecy for a comment had been seen
above King's Landing on the night taker
most conceived and Rhaegar was stirring
the bleeding star had to be a comet but
full Sivir who thought herself so wise
Rhaegar was born in Targaryen summer
palace summer home surely after a curse
brewed the palace was consumed by a
great fire which claimed life of king
egg and the fifth matron was brought her
along with the king's son in here many
tears were shed for those who died
Rhaegar was literally born amid smoking
salt fulfilling the born amid smoke a
soul part of the azor Ahai prophecy
regard for the line of the Mad King and
realtor Garion him being the firstborn
son
according to legend Osric eyes first
attempts to create light bringer failed
he succeeded in his third attempt to
force his weapon that will defeat the
darkness but he had to sacrifice the
love of his life as in order to unleash
the weapons true powers he had to plunge
it into the part of his loving wife nice
Aneesa the successful creation of the
weapon resulted with the death of his
beloved wife nice a niece who was said
to cry out in both language and ecstasy
when Ezra high-tempered the blade by
driving into her heart
similarly johnston was Rhaegar's third
child and his creation resulted in the
death of Reger's beloved wife Lena Stark
who could be heard by her brother either
crying out in anguish in ecstasy from
inside the tower of joy as she was
giving birth to her son in then his
vision of past in The Clash of Kings
Rhaegar said that his son is the prince
that was promised as given from star as
the prophecies can be tricky as in this
theory his son is not actually Prince
but rather the weapon library created by
Asura hi Rhaegar himself and his wife
Nissa Nissa Lyanna stark ironically it
turns out that Rhaegar was right the
first time himself was azor Ahai all
along Lina was his niece and his sign
Genesis creation light bringer riggers
weapon that will defeat the night King
Endon long night perhaps a song of ice
and fire is the melody at Rhaegar
composed when he create his son who
would go on to become the weapon that
will kill the night king and save all of
Westeros from the long night and as
always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe
they hope the seen the next one peace
[Music]